Guten Tag, mein Name ist Doha. Ich bin heute der diensthabende Arzt und würde jetzt gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Herr Doktor, ich bin hier seit zwei Stunden und ich habe seit lang gewartet. Warum?
Ja, es tut mir leid, dass Sie so lange warten müssen, aber wir sind im Krankenhaus. Es gibt viele Patienten und es gibt viel los. Aber machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Jetzt bin ich für Sie da und kümmere mich um Ihre Sorgen, Ihre Beschwerde. Ok?
Ja, könnten Sie bitte schnell erledigen. Ok?
Ich versuche das so schnell wie möglich zu erledigen. Ja, wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Meier Wurtwald.
Meier Wurtwald. Könnten Sie das langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
M-A-J-A-W-Ü-R-D-T-W-A-L-D
Wie wie Wilhelm?
Ja, stimmt.
Frau Wurtwald, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
46 Jahre alt. Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 1.1.1980.
80? Könnten Sie das wiederholen? Ja, ok.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Wurtwald?
Ein Meter und 67.
Ok. Wissen Sie wie viel Sie wegen?
Ungefähr 78 Kilo, Herr Doktor.
78 Kilo. Ok.
Ja, Frau Wurtwald, was führt Sie heute zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Herr Doktor, ich bin sehr nervös und seit langer Zeit habe ich Herzrasen.
Sie fühlen sich nervös und Sie haben Herzrasen.
Ja. Hab ich richtig verstanden. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ungefähr vier Wochen. Und manchmal geht und kommt nicht immer.
Wenn ich fühle mich sehr nervös und ich habe sehr starke Herzklopfen.
Herzklopfen. Ok.
Gibt es einen Auslöser für diese Schmerzen? Für Herzrasen und Nervosität?
Haben Sie das bemerkt? Vielleicht haben Sie sich verletzt oder Schlafstörungen oder Trauma?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe keinen Auslöser. Ok.
Haben Sie neben dem Herzrasen und Nervosität andere Beschwerden? Zum Beispiel Schwindel oder?
Ich habe seit zwei Wochen Schwindel.
Seit zwei Wochen oder vor zwei Wochen? Hab ich nicht gut verstanden.
Mein Herzrasen vor vier Wochen, aber Schwindel seit zwei Wochen.
Seit immer? Ist immer Schwindel oder wie Atakanartisch?
Atakanartisch Schwindel.
Ich hatte Schwindel-Attaken seit zwei Wochen.
Und ich habe zusätzlich das Gewissleid verloren.
Ich konnte nicht das Gewissleid verloren.
Ich hatte zweimal Ataken und konnte mich nicht daran erinnern.
Wenn ich aufwache, habe ich einige Eingenäste bemerkt.
Wie oft hatten Sie diese Attacken und wie lange haben diese Attacken gedauert?
Herzrasenattacken dauern ungefähr fünf oder fünfzehn Minuten.
Aber ich weiß genau nichts.
Aber die Gewissleidung dauerte ungefähr ein bis zwei Minuten.
Ja, das habe ich verstanden.
Sie war eingenehm, wenn Sie aufgewacht haben.
Okay, Sie sind verloren.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie Seher oder Erstörungen haben?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme mit Seher oder Erstörungen.
Als Sie aufgewacht haben, waren Sie aufgefallen, dass Sie dabei auf die Sunge gebissen haben?
Ich habe keine Probleme mit Seher oder Erstörungen.
Okay.
Könnten Sie Ihr Schwindel genau beschreiben?
Wie ein Karussel oder wie auf dem Boot?
Ich habe die Gewissleidung verloren.
Das erste Mal war es zwei Wochen und das zweite Mal zehn Tage.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was Sie Schwindel meinen.
Können Sie bitte erklären?
Ja, das ist einfach. Ich kann es auch wieder formulieren.
Fühlen Sie sich während des Sehens wie auf dem Boot?
Ich weiß nicht. Zuerst hatte ich ein Herzrasen, dann kam ich wieder weg.
Ich konnte mich nicht erinnern.
Okay.
Frau Gürtwald, haben Sie ein großes Gefühl im Hals bemerkt?
Ja, stimmt.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ungefähr vier Wochen.
Auch vier Wochen. Und haben Sie Heiserkeit oder Schluckstörungen?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie eine Vergrößerung am Hals bemerkt haben?
Herr Doktor, Sie können das überprüfen.
Natürlich. Ich werde Sie ausführlich und korpherlich untersuchen.
Aber diese Fragen und diese Antworten, die Sie mir geben, sind sehr wichtig.
Deswegen frage ich danach.
Können Sie das beantworten? Ich bin kein Arzt.
Herr Doktor, Frau Gürtwald.
Okay, wir können diese Frage verpassen.
Sind Sie über empfindlich gegenüber Wärme?
Ja, Sie wissen das. Heute ist es sehr kalt.
Aber ich wünsche, das Fenster zu öffnen.
Und ja, ich habe eine wernende Toleranz.
Ich bin schwitzt und schwitze immer als Song.
Manchmal muss ich mein Kleid und Hose wechseln.
Okay, das habe ich auch alle Informationen notiert.
Wenn ich nervös bin, sind meine beiden Hände selbstständig.
Haben Sie auch ein Taubheitsgefühl oder ein Kreben an Ihren Körper?
Nein.
Okay, nur sitzend.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Konzentrationsstörungen, Frau Gürtwald?
Ja, früher war alles in Ordnung.
Aber seit vier Wochen konnte ich nicht fixieren und konzentrieren.
Ich möchte nicht arbeiten.
Ich bin sehr stark nervös.
Es ist wichtig, alle Informationen zu wissen.
Um eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen. Danke für die Informationen.
Herr Gürtwald, ich habe Angst vor Umkippen.
Was machen Sie für mich? Ich habe sehr Angst.
Ich habe schon gesagt, dass ich zweimal umgekippt habe.
Ihre Angst kann ich gut nachvollziehen, Frau Gürtwald.
Aber wir sind im Krankenhaus und werden alle notwendig untersuchen,
um das abzuklären und bestmögliche Vorsorge zu bieten.
Okay, bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. Sie sind in guten Händen.
Frau Gürtwald, schwitzen Sie mehr als sonst?
Ja, ich habe schon gesagt.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber, Stellfrost, Nachtschweiß auch?
Ich habe keine Fieber und Stellfrost nicht.
Sie leiden unter der Straße.
Deswegen ist es sehr wichtig für mich zu wissen,
ob Sie auch Brustschmerzen oder Atemnot haben.
Nein, ich habe keine Brustschmerzen.
Okay, gut. Und auch Atemnot? Leiden Sie darunter?
Okay, ich habe das kurz zu wissen.
Das habe ich auch notiert.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie ...
Manchmal habe ich einen komischen Geräusch im Ohr.
Wenn ich eine Herzrasen habe, was für eine ...
Das kann sein.
Diese Herzrasen ...
Es kann einen Zusammenhang zwischen Ihren Herzrasen und diesen komischen Geräuschen geben.
Aber wie gesagt, werden wir das auch untersuchen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde, ich meine die komischen Geräusche?
Gleichzeitig, ungefähr seit vier Wochen.
Okay. Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie auch Übelkeit oder Erbrechen haben.
Übelkeit oder Erbrechen habe ich nicht.
Gut, zu wissen. Haben Sie Probleme mit der Stuhlgang?
Mein Stuhl ist ein bisschen wässrig, aber ich muss zweimal täglich zur Toilette gehen.
Aber es sieht ganz normal aus.
Normal aus, okay.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Meck.
Danke für die Information.
Wie sieht es mit dem Wasserlassen aus, Frau Wirtwald?
Wasserlassen ist ganz normal.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Herr Doktor, ich muss alles essen.
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Trotzdem habe ich seit vier Wochen vier Kilo abgenommen.
In vier Wochen?
Ja.
Okay, wichtig zu wissen.
Frau Wirtwald, können Sie gut schlafen oder haben Sie Probleme mit Schlafen?
Manchmal habe ich einen Herzhasen und ich konnte nicht gut schlafen.
Ich habe seit vier Wochen Schlafen und mein Schlaf ist nicht so gut, aber nicht so schlimm.
Aber ich konnte seit vier Wochen nicht schlafen.
Wie gesagt, machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Wir versuchen Ihre aller Beschwerden zu lösen oder eine Lösung zu finden.
Frau Wirtwald, Sie sind 46 Jahre alt.
Bekommen Sie Ihre Periode noch?
Ich habe regelmäßig Monat Blutung.
Wann war der letzte Monat Blutung?
Meine letzte Messtuation war vor zwei Wochen.
Ich nehme eine Tablette, ein Mal morgens.
Herr Doktor, ich habe mit meinem 19.Jahren eine Blintam-Entzündung diagnostiziert.
Ich habe mir die Blintam entführt und sie haben mir gesagt, dass er Endometriose war.
Aber was ist Endometriose? Seitdem vertraue ich nicht mehr.
Frau Wirtwald, ich verstehe Ihre Enttäuschung.
Es ist schwierig, die Endometriose-Diagnose zu stellen.
Endometriose und Blintam-Entzündung haben sehr nische Symptome.
Aus dieser Perspektive erscheint die Operation sinnvoll.
Endometriose ist eine Geber-Mutter-Schleimhaut-Krankheit.
Die Geber-Mutter-Schleimhaut kann die Geber-Mutter-Schleimhaut nicht verbrechen.
War das schwierig?
Wir nennen das Endometriose.
Das kann leider sein.
Danke schön, Herr Doktor.
Außer Endometriose gibt es in Ihrer Vorlage Geschichtskrankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Zum Beispiel koreische Erkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit oder?
Nichts.
Okay.
Außer dieser Appendektomie wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, im Alter von 25 Jahren.
Ich habe eine Tuberleiter-Operation.
Wegen Geschichtskrankheiten oder Wegen Endometriose?
Ich weiß nicht, aber operativ behandelt.
Meine Frau und Doktor haben gesagt, dass ich eine Tuber-Gravität habe.
Ja.
Entschuldigung, ich habe verpasst. Wann war diese Operation?
Mit meinen 25 Jahren.
Okay, das habe ich auch notiert. Danke für diese Informationen.
Sie haben eben schon gesagt, dass Sie gegen Endometriose Minolet-Ingen nur einnehmen.
Außer Minolet nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Wenn ich einen Schlafstörmchen habe, nehme ich manchmal Badriandragien ein.
Okay, bei Bedarf können wir auch sagen.
Frau Wirtwald, sind Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten?
Frau Wirtwald, Allergien sind eine überempfindliche Reaktion gegen harmlose Stoffe.
Tierhaare, Polen oder andere.
Aber Unverträglichkeiten sind anders.
Vielleicht, wenn man ein Lebensmittel oder etwas nicht gut ertragen kann, nennen wir das Unverträglichkeiten.
Beispielsweise Laktosintoleranz oder Glutininverträglichkeit.
Können wir dazu sehen?
Wenn ich nach dem Krankenhaus gehe und eine Brannefilaste aufreiche,
dann habe ich ein bisschen Rötung und Schwellung.
Okay, mit Rötung und Schwellung.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen oder ob Sie früher geraucht haben?
Ich bin nur nicht Raucherin.
Ja, sehr gut. Ich gratuliere Ihnen. Trinkenseil kommt?
Gelegentlich am Wochenende zwei Gläser Wein, aber nicht immer.
Routinemäßig muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie mit irgendwelchen Drogen Kontakt haben?
Ja, keine Kontakt mit dem Drogen.
Das ist gut.
Jetzt würde ich Ihnen gerne einige Fragen zu Ihren Familien stellen.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch oder sind Sie gesund?
Mein Vater ist an Blutvergiftung gestorben und er litt an Gift.
Meine Mutter lebt noch und sie hat eine chronische Darmenentzündung, Herr Doktor.
Okay, eine chronische Darmenentzündung.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin nur Lady, aber ich bin in einer homosexuellen Beziehung und lesbisch bin ich, ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Schuhverkäuferin seit 20 Jahren. Ich bin zufrieden mit meiner Arbeit.
Haben Sie Stress zu Hause auch oder bei der Arbeit?
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Sowohl bei der Arbeit als auch zu Hause haben Sie keinen Stress. Das ist gut zu wissen.
Okay, Frau Wirtwald, ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit und Ihre Geduld.
Ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Laut Ihrer Beschwerden habe ich den Verdacht auf Schildrüsse über Funktionen.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung. Deshalb müssen wir weiter untersuchen und durchführen um das zu bestätigen.
Zunächst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen, Ihnen anschließend etwas Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Danach werde ich eine EKG schreiben um mögliche Herzursachen auszuschlissen.
Und ich werde eine Halsultraschall durchführen.
Wissen Sie was das ist?
Ja, ich weiß.
Sobald Ihre Befunde voll liegen beschütze ich alles mit meinem Oberarzt.
Dann komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und erkläre Ihnen Schritt für Schritt wie es weitergeht.
Sie können bleiben und auf mich warten. Ich komme gleich.
Ich bin Frau Müller und ich bin aus dem Labor.
Frau Riedl, Hemoglobinwerte 6,27 Gramm pro Liter.
Er wie Emil und El.
Können Sie bitte diese Werte Ihren Oberarzt weiterleiten?
Ja natürlich, das ist ein wichtiges Wort. Ich mache das gerne süßlich. Danke. Tschüss.
Guten Tag. Erdogan.
Können Sie sich kurz vorstellen?
Ich heiße Çetin Doğan und komme aus der Türkei.
Ich bin 41 Jahre alt und lebe seit etwas mehr als eineinhalb Jahren in Deutschland.
Seitdem oder inzwischen habe ich...
Was haben Sie in Deutschland bisher gemacht?
Ja, inzwischen habe ich intensiv Deutsch gelernt.
Außerdem habe ich versucht in Deutschland besser mit meiner ganzen Familie zu integrieren.
Eigentlich bin ich verheiratet und habe zwei Söhne.
Ist Ihre Frau Arztin?
Ja, sie ist Zahnärztin.
Aber jetzt darf sie auch nicht arbeiten.
Obwohl sie die Fachsprachprüfung bestanden hat, darf sie nicht momentan arbeiten.
Aber sie sucht eine Stelle.
Viele Arbeitgeber oder Praxisbesitzer möchten nicht ohne Arbeitsabprobation einen Arzt oder einen Zahnarzt einarbeiten.
Deswegen ist es sehr schwer eine Stelle zu finden.
Aber wir versuchen eine Stelle zu finden.
Sie hat schon eine Berufserlebnisse, aber sie hat keine Arbeitsabprobation.
Deswegen ist es schwierig eine Stelle zu finden.
Bei Zahnärztin ist es ein bisschen schwer als bei Arztin.
Vielen Dank für die Information. Ich habe bisher nicht gewusst.
Inzwischen engagiere ich mich neben dem Deutsch lernen.
Ich engagiere mich ehrenamtlich zum Beispiel beim Verein GENO EIFEL.
Ich finde es wirklich interessant.
Darf ich?
Okay, Frage.
Was haben Sie gemacht als Ehrenamt?
Hat das für die Menschen geholfen?
Ja, tatsächlich ist es so.
GENO EIFEL ist eine generationenübergreifende Genossenschaft in der Eifel.
Die Menschen unterstützen und zusammenhalten sich gegenseitig im Alltag.
Vielleicht kann man unterstützen oder kann man anderen Menschen helfen durch unterhalten, zuhören oder lesen, begleiten, beim Einkauf oder Krankenhäuser besuchen.
Es gibt viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten, den Menschen zu helfen.
Okay, ja, das ist sehr schön und sehr hilfreich, in Deutschlands Alltag zu integrieren.
Ja, wir versuchen immer, wie gesagt, in unser neues Land zu integrieren.
Aber wie Sie vermuten, ist es nicht einfach, mit diesem Alter ein neues Leben, ein neues Land zu integrieren.
Ich kann verstehen. Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Ja, ich habe heute eine Patientin aufgenommen.
Aber bevor ich meine Patienten vorstellen möchte, muss ich etwas Wichtiges mit Ihnen teilen.
Ich habe einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Ich soll Ihnen sagen, Frau Riedl hat einen Hemoglobinwert von 6,27 Gramm Dessiliter.
Das ist sehr stark erniedrigt und entspricht Anämie.
Okay, wissen Sie, welche Ursache gibt es für Anämie?
Allgemein weiß ich es natürlich, aber für diese Patientin habe ich keine Ahnung.
Weil ich diese Patientin bis jetzt nicht untersucht habe oder auch gesehen habe.
Aber allgemeine Ursachen kann ich gerne erklären.
Ich habe gefragt, allgemein.
Okay, die häufigste Ursache dafür ist Eisenmangelanämie.
Oder Blutverluste, zum Beispiel geneakologische Blutverluste oder Fehlernährung kann sein.
Aber die häufigste ist Eisenmangelanämie.
Je nach dem Zellvolumen können wir drei Arten der Anämie einteilen.
Normosterre, Mikrosterre und Makrosterre-Anämie.
Wie gesagt, häufigst ist Mikrosterre-Anämie im Rahmen des Eisenmangels.
Okay, welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei Anämie?
Ja, allgemein erwarte ich Bläse, Möglichkeit, Leistungsunfähigkeit, Tachikalie, Schwindeldüspne.
Kann dazu gezählt werden.
Kardialkar, natürlich Belastung, Düspne oder Angina Pectoris kann sein.
Zum Beispiel bei B12-Mangel kann man auch viele noch weitere neurologische Symptome wie Parasthesen, Gangstörungen oder kognitive Störungen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Es gibt noch eine Frage hier. Wie kann man unterschieden zwischen akute und chronische Anämie?
Ja, kann man durch Anamnestisch und durch Untersuchung.
Ja, unter akuten und chronischen Anämnestischen.
Labo oder nur Anamnestisch?
Je nach der Anamnestischen Angaben kann man untersuchen, aber vielleicht vor der Geschichte des Patienten kann man auch zum Beispiel eine genekologische Anamnese.
Wenn die Patientin bei genekologischen Anamnese eine übermäßige Monatsblutung oder direkt Mensuration berichtete, ist das eine Zeichen für chronische Prozesse.
Oder zum Beispiel eine jetzige oder ein Trauma oder eine Verletzung wie Epistaxis oder Blutung in einem Unfall bezeichnet man als akuter Verlust.
Ja, Sie haben sehr gut erklärt. Und was erwarten Sie bei körperlicher Untersuchung bei akute Anämie?
Ja, akute Anämie. Natürlich sind die Symptome ausgeprägt als chronische Anämie.
Daran können die Körper bei der chronischen Anämie an die Symptome gewonnen. Deswegen erwarten wir die Symptome nicht so ausgeprägt als akute Anämie.
Meinen Sie so oder?
Ja, ich meine so. Und bei der körperlichen Untersuchung können wir Tachikardi erwarten.
Ja, natürlich.
Ok, was haben Sie noch für uns?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe eine neue Patientin in der Notaufnahme aufgenommen. Es geht um Frau Maja Wirtwald. Sie ist 46 Jahre alt, geboren am 01.01.1970.
Sie ist 1,67 Meter groß und wiegt 78 Kilo.
Sie kam heute zu uns wegen seit vier Wochen bestehender Herzrasen, Nervosität und auch seit zwei Wochen bestehender Schwindel.
Schwindelattacken und Kopen sind ein bisschen verwirrt wegen dieser kompensierten Angaben. Aber ich kann es so zusammenfassen.
Laut der Patientin sind die Schmerzen plötzlich attackartig aufgetreten. Nach Angaben der Patientin dauert jede Attacke 15 Minuten.
Außerdem berichtet sie, wie gesagt, dass sie insgesamt zwei Schwindelkörper hatte. Die erste war vor zwei Wochen und die letzte war vor zehn Tagen.
Während der Synkopen habe ich die Patientin eingeschränkt und sie sich auf die Muskelsuchungen verneint.
Begleitend klagt sie über Globusgefühl, Wärme und Toleranz, Nervosität, Konzentrationsstörung, auch Tinnitus. Seit vier Wochen leidet sie an Tinnitus.
Sie hat eine Gewichtsabnahme von vier Kilo innerhalb von vier Wochen trotz Heißunger.
Sie hat eine Weichstuhl und eine dünne Stuhl. Vegetativanamnistisch ergab sich insomnie wegen der Tachikarte bedingt.
Der Patient leidet seit dem 18. Lebensjahr an Endometriose. Die letzte Periode war vor 14 Tagen.
An Operationen ist eine Tonsilektomie, eine Appendektomie sowie eine Extrauterin-Gravität bekannt. Sie nimmt Minolet regelmäßig und bei Bedarf Valdrian ein.
Sie hat Allergien gegen Braunosflaschen, die sich durch Erutem und Ödema äußern.
Bei der Nuxanamnese berichteten die Patienten über einen Konsum von zwei Gläser Wein pro Woche. Nikotin und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Die Familienanamnese ergab Sepsis und Arthritis Eureka bei dem Vater und Morbus Crohn bei der Mutter.
Sozialanamnistisch ist sie ledig, hat eine homosexuelle Beziehung und arbeitet als Schuhverkäuferin.
Haben Sie Fragen bezüglich der anamnistischen Angaben?
Momentan habe ich keine Fragen. Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Nach anamnistischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf eine Hyperthyroese.
Ich habe Angst vor umkippen, Nervosität, Konzentrationsstörungen, Wärmeintoleranz, Gewichtsabnahme trotz Heizungen und Tremor der Hände, weiche Stühle und Hyperthyroese.
Die Differenzialdiagnose ist eine Herzrhythmusstörung.
Vielleicht Paroxysmal, ja, vor allem kann man sein, aber auch, den lateinischen Begriff habe ich vergessen, Paroxysmal-supraventikulare Tachikarde kann sein,
auch weil der Patient jung ist, überwiegt, ich muss nicht so erklären, auch Differenzialdiagnose kann kommen, auch eine Panikattacke in Betracht, ich denke.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich natürlich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen, Blut für das Labor abnehmen,
außerdem sollte ein EKG durchgeführt werden, um eine mögliche Herzrhythmusstörung auszuschließen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, es gibt viele Zeichen bezüglich Hyperthyroese.
Von Kopf zu Fuß muss ich ausführlich untersuchen, vielleicht eine, die Haut, ja, genäßte oder genäßte, ich habe vergessen das Adjektiv, aber genäßte oder?
Nassende Haut?
Nassende Haut, vielleicht eine, feuchte Haut, zum Beispiel im Rahmen des Morbus basado als eine Ursache für Hyperthyroese,
bei den Patienten mit Morbus basado im Rahmen des Hyperthyroese können wir exophtalmie beobachten oder erwarten.
Was ist Morbus basado?
Das ist eine, ja, Otto Emusche.
Denken Sie immer einfacher, der Prüfer oder die Prüferin möchte hören, Schittrusepalpation, Abtasten der Schittruse.
Dann sollen Sie Abtasten der Schittruse erklären.
Ja, Sie haben richtig erklärt, von Kopf bis Fuß, Haarausfall, feuchte Haut oder Exophtalmie, Sie sind alle richtig, aber die Prüferin möchte nur Abtasten der Schittruse hören.
Ok, ja, ich erwarte bei der körperlichen Untersuchung der Schittruse eine Vergrößerung der Schittruse, aber natürlich sollten wir die Schittruse untersuchen.
Wie können Sie die Schittruse untersuchen?
Ja, ich stehe hinter den Patienten und greife den Hals mit meinen Händen durch meine Fingerinnenfläche,
und ob es eine Vergrößerung oder einen Knoten gibt, kann ich einfach untersuchen und wahrscheinlich kann ich das herausfinden.
Ich habe gefragt, was ist Morus Pasedo?
Morus Pasedo ist eine autoimmunische Schildrüsenkrankheit, wie gesagt, die das Krankbild überwiegt, oder nicht überwiegend,
durch die sich durch Hyperhidrose äußert, oder die äußert, ja, eine autoimmunische Schildrüsenkrankheit, die sich durch Hyperhidrose äußert. Kann man so sagen?
Hyperhidrose, Hyperhidrose.
Ja, kann man sagen. Aber es ist eine Autoimmunerkrankung, das kann Hyperthyroso, Schittruseüberfanktion verursachen,
und das ist Exophthalmos, auch andere, Vergrößerung der Hals, es gibt drei, ein Triad, Exophthalmos, Vergrößerung der Hals und Tachikardi, gekennzeichnet.
Alle Satze sind kurz, aber deutlich. Das sind Autoimmunerkrankungen, das kann Hyperthyroso verursachen, und so den Symptomen gehören, Exophthalmos, Vergrößerung der Hals und Tachikardi.
Ja, wenn man kurze Satze benutzt, dann kann man flüssiger sprechen.
Sie haben nichts.
Sie haben sehr sehr gute Kenntnisse, und auch sie sprechen sehr sehr gut. Aber wenn sie schöne Satze bilden möchte, dann sprechen sie langsamer als.
Sehr langsamer.
Ja, leider.
Eigentlich langsamer ist nicht so wichtig, aber sie sehen ein bisschen verwirrt aus. Deswegen kurze Satze, kurze Erklärung, aber viele Satze. Ist besser, meiner Meinung nach.
Sie haben ganz recht, völlig recht. Aber ich versuche das zu schaffen, weil ich so daran gewöhnt habe, ist das für mich sehr schwer, meine Gewohnheiten oder Sprachverhältnisse zu verändern. Aber ich versuche, ich muss versuchen, das zu machen. Danke.
Sie müssen nicht so machen. Vielleicht ihr Sprachverhalten, wie so, kann schneller sein mit der Zeit.
Ja, sicher.
Okay, weiter. Welche weitere Diagnostikmethode möchten Sie durchführen?
Ja, wie gesagt, Blut, ja, ich muss Blut. Im Labor würde ich natürlich ein Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Leber- und Nierenwerte, Elektrolyte, auch Schildrisenparameter, TSH, Freit FF, T3, Freit F4 oder Antikoren wie Trag oder Anti-TPO und kontrollieren lassen.
Darüber hinaus werde ich eine Schildrisen-Sonographie durchführen und auch eine langseitige EKG.
Ich habe am Anfang eine bariköpäliche Untersuchung. Zuerst werde ich eine Ruhe-EKG durchführen, aber gegebenenfalls langseitige EKG sollte durchgeführt werden.
Sie haben Panikattack als finanzielles Diagnostik genannt. Hat die Patientin Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Privatleben?
Obwohl die Patientin entweder bei der Arbeit oder weder bei der Arbeit noch zu Hause Stress hat, denke ich, dass es eine Differenzielle Diagnostik ist.
Sie haben auch eine Panikattack, weil sie die sympathischen Symptome der Panikattacken hat.
Ich habe nicht gut ausgedacht.
Nein, ich habe verstanden. Die Symptome oder die Beschwerden passen zu einer Panikattack.
Ich meine, ohne Stress vielleicht.
Aber normalerweise erwarten wir keine Senkope bei Panikattacken. Umkippen ist möglich, aber Senkope erwarten wir nicht.
Aber das ist nicht notwendig oder nicht wichtig. Hauptsache ist, dass Sie etwas gegen meine Frage sagen oder meine Frage antworten.
Aber ich würde gerne wissen, um mehr zu erfahren über Panikattacken, weil Sie Physiotherist sind.
Ich möchte in meiner Improfung die Panikattacken als eine Differenzielle Diagnose nennen. Deswegen würde ich gerne wissen, vielleicht ausführlich über Panikattacken.
Könnten Sie mir dabei helfen, wenn man Panikattacken als Differenzielle Diagnose schreibt? Worauf sollte man achten?
Wenn Sie Panikattacken als Differenzielle Diagnose nennen möchten, sollten Sie bei der Anamnese-Gesprache ein paar Fragen stellen.
Zum Beispiel haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Privatleben? Gibt es eine Auslöser für diese Beschwerden? Was haben Sie gemacht, bevor Ihre Beschwerden aufgetreten sind?
Am Anfang erwarten wir meistens eine Auslöser, eine stressige Situation, bevor die Panikattack aufgetreten ist.
Aber später, ohne Auslöser, können die Beschwerden oder kann Panikattack aufgetreten sein.
Aber bei der Panikattack erwarten wir sehr große Angst. Aber große Angst vor Sterben, vor Herzstillstand oder Herzinfarkt oder vor Schlaganfall oder vor ohne Luft zu bekommen.
Aber auch vor verrückt zu sein. Aber keine Angst vor Unkeeping. Aber diese Beschwerden passen zu Panikattacken, weil Panikattacken symptomatische Hyperaktivierung verursacht.
Wie Hyperthrose. Deswegen können Sie als Panikattack-Differenzielle Diagnose aussehen.
Ok, ok. Das war sehr hilfreich für mich. Vielen Dank.
Ok. Wie können Sie die Patienten behandeln?
Ja, sollte sich die Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Es gibt einen Konflikt zwischen stationär und ambulant. Ich bevorzuge die Patienten stationär aufzunehmen.
Ja, ich vorgehe sogar auch. Warum möchten Sie die Patienten stationär aufnehmen?
Ja, die Symptome sind ausgeprägter. Vielleicht können die Patienten mögliche Synkopen beschädigt werden.
In der Geschichte gab es Synkopen. Das ist sehr entscheidend für mich, diese Patienten stationär aufzunehmen.
Und auch, je nach Ergebnisse, ist das ausreichend für mich.
Das ist ausreichend. Sie können ein paar Satzen und fertig. Sie müssen nicht viele, viele Erklärungen machen.
In der Vorgeschichte gibt es zwei Mal Synkope. Deswegen möchte ich auf jeden Fall die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Synkop kann gefährlich sein. Bittes, so viel. Du musst nicht mehr so viele.
Synkop ist schon genug. Zwei, drei Menschen, eine Frau, ein Fahrzeug. Wenn Synkop passiert, ist die Leben vorbei.
Das muss schnell verstanden werden. Ich würde als Therapie ein Throstatikum verordnen.
Vielleicht kann man die Patienten stationär aufnehmen. So wie man einen Betablok verordnen kann.
Ich werde die aktive Schildrüsenhormone reduzieren.
Vielen Dank. Sie haben sehr gut gemacht. Danke für alle Rückmeldungen. Ich werde darauf achten.
Wenn du dich nervös fühlst, kannst du dich nicht mehr bewegen.
Du kannst dich nicht mehr bewegen. Du kannst dich nicht mehr bewegen.
Du kannst dich nicht mehr bewegen.
Wenn du die Symptome für Hyperthrose beantworten kannst,
dann ist es nicht nötig, die ganze Zeit zu fragen.
dann ist es nicht nötig, die ganze Zeit zu fragen,
ob es vielleicht eine Verkroßung gibt,
oder ein Globusgefühl.
Dann ist es nicht nötig, die ganze Zeit zu fragen,
ob es eine Verkroßung gibt,
oder ein Globusgefühl.
Wenn du die Symptome für Hyperthrose beantworten kannst,
dann ist es nicht nötig, die ganze Zeit zu fragen,
ob es eine Verkroßung gibt,
dann ist es nicht nötig,
aber ich fühle mich immer warm,
ich muss immer das Fenster aufmachen.
Das sagt man dort, das kann kommen.
Wenn es nicht kommen würde, dann ist es kein Problem.
Kilo, Heißung, das ist schon eine Wekathedrahmnese.
Hyperthrose hat viele, viele Fragen.
Wenn man die ganzen Fragen fragt,
dann kann man nicht mehr lange wachsen.
Das ist Stress.
Wie ich von Erfarbungen habe,
sagt man viele Dinge,
wenn man einen stressigen Mann spielt.
Du hast diesen Patienten sehr gut gestaltet.
Er hat ihn in der Stressung entspannen,
er hat ihn helfen lassen, ihn finden lassen.
Ich finde, er war sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.
Sümayra, ich möchte die Frage wiederholen.
Haben Sie noch andere Probleme?
Haben Sie gleichzeitig Herzrasen?
Nein, es gibt noch andere Probleme,
die gleichzeitig aufstehen.
Zum Beispiel eine Verkroßung des Halsbemerks,
oder ein Gluckgefühl.
Das ist ein Problem.
Sie können dort die Symptome,
die Sie wollen,
in die Hyperthrose legen.
Sie können die anderen Symptome
auch immer noch sagen.
Aber nach dem Erfüllung der Symptome,
die Anna-Hassan gesagt hat,
habe ich sie mir beantwortet.
Dann habe ich direkt eine Frage,
die ich sie mir beantwortet habe.
Ich habe sie mir durchgeführt,
dass ich sie mir beantwortet habe.
Dann hab ich sie mir gesagt.
Ich habe sie mir beantwortet.
Und dann habe ich sie mir beantwortet.
Jetzt bin ich über die Urne durchgeführt.
Dann habe ich sie mir beantwortet.
Ich habe sie mir beantwortet.
Herr Schäfer, bitte.
Hier steht, dass Herr Saersen und Anxfor um Kupen kommen.
Anxfor um Kupen wird als Senkop getragen, oder?
Nein, nein, nein. Um Kupen nicht Senkop.
Um Kupen Senkop bedeutet nicht.
Um Kupen kann es in Kollaps sein, auch Senkop.
In der Frage, die mir der Prof. Ibrahim geschrieben hat,
wird um Kupen auch um die beiden verlaufen.
Aber in Kollaps wird das nicht um die beiden verlaufen.
Nur da gibt es die Muskeltonusverlust.
Aber in Senkop wird das auch um die beiden verlaufen.
Muskeltonusverlust und um die beiden verlaufen.
Anxfor um Kupen sagt,
dass wir sagen, dass wir um Kupen sind.
Wenn wir das sagen, dann sagt er,
dass wir zwei mal um Kupen sind.
Wenn er das sagt, dann sagen wir, dass wir Senkop sind.
Verstanden. Danke.
Der Grund ist Kollaps und Senkop.
In Kollaps gibt es Beavusdineferlon und Ferlorin.
Es gibt Muskeltonusverlust.
In Senkop gibt es Beavusdineferlorin und Muskeltonusverlust.
Aber um Kupen zu sagen,
dass wir um Kollaps und Senkop um die beiden verlaufen.
Wir wissen es.
Wie wir es um die beiden verlaufen?
Wenn es um Beavusdineferlorin gibt, dann sagen wir Senkop.
Wenn es um Beavusdineferlorin geht,
dann sagen wir Kollaps.
Aber der Patient sagt nicht, dass es um Beavusdineferlorin geht.
Er hat es nicht so gemacht.
Okay, ich versuche das zu verstehen.
Meine Frage ist,
ob es um Beavusdineferlorin geht.
Ich sage, dass es um Beavusdineferlorin geht.
Ich habe hier die Frage.
Darum gibt es keine weitere Antwort.
Ich habe die Frage.
Es gibt Protokolle,
aber es ist nicht sinnvoll,
wenn es um Beavusdineferlorin geht.
Ich habe die Frage.
Es gibt Protokolle,
aber es ist nicht sinnvoll,
wenn es um Beavusdineferlorin geht.
Ich habe die Frage.
Es gibt Protokolle,
aber es ist nicht sinnvoll,
wenn es um Beavusdineferlorin geht.
Ich habe die Frage.
Es gibt Protokolle,
aber es ist nicht sinnvoll,
wenn es um Beavusdineferlorin geht.
Es gibt Protokolle,
aber es ist nicht sinnvoll,
wenn es um Beavusdineferlorin geht.
Ich habe die Frage.
Es gibt Protokolle,
aber es ist nicht sinnvoll,
wenn es um Beavusdineferlorin geht.
Ich habe die Frage.
Es gibt Protokolle,
aber es ist nicht sinnvoll,
wenn es um Beavusdineferlorin geht.
Es gibt Protokolle,
aber es ist nicht sinnvoll,
wenn es um Beavusdineferlorin geht.
Es gibt Protokolle,
Ich bin tot, ich werde verrückt.
Oder ich werde sterben.
Ich werde mich verletzen, ich werde schlafen bleiben, ich kann nicht atmen.
Ich habe diese Angst vor mir.
Und es ist ein sehr langweiliger Angst.
Ein Telefon klingelt.
Ist es etwas, das ich schlecht wissen werde?
Oder mein Sohn wird sterben oder so?
Nein.
Das ist die Angst.
Aber es kann auch Panikattack sein.
Panikattacken sind eine Art Panikattack.
Aber es gibt immer Panikattacken.
Es gibt immer Angst vor Panikattacken.
Panikattacken können in jeder Art und Weise sein.
Man kann auch Panikattacken machen, ohne dass es eine Angst gibt.
Panikattacken sind ein sehr intensives, sympathisches Aktivation.
Das bedeutet, dass es eine sehr intensive, sympathische Aktivation gibt.
Eine intensive Herzschlag, Schmerzen, Schmerzen der Füße, eine sehr intensive Angst.
Also alles sympathische Aktivation, das in der Körper sein kann.
Danke.
Bitte.
Dann schalte ich.